fin de campagne animée pour jean marie
le pen le président du front national a
été vigoureusement chahutée par des
manifestants ce matin à mantes la jolie
où il était venu soutenir la candidature
de sa fille la candidate socialiste a
été légèrement blessé au cours de ces
échauffourées commentaires michaël
darmon sur des images chimie patrice
desmulie
jean marie le pen en visite à mantes la
jolie des militants anti fn l'accueil
dès la sortie de la voiture un garde du
corps écarté manifestants qui se
précipitent la bagarre commence public
[Applaudissements]
m
on le voit ici on ralentit hors de lui
jean marie le pen plaque contre le mur
la candidate socialiste à ned paul bass
berges à re
découvrir
un policier tente alors de le calmer
arrêté
là
me sourire et plaqué mais le tour de la
visite est donnée venue soutenir sa
fille marie caroline il se dirige vers
le centre ville ses gardes du corps
libère le passage à leur manière
[Applaudissements]
tout ce parcours est jalonnée
d'incidents entre manifestants et
policiers et militants fn
lui-même de plusieurs et il va le
montrer une deuxième fois surprenant son
entourage jean marie le pen se rejette
dans la bagarre
[Musique]
j'étais à courir moi tu voles andrew
kg né
à celui
fin de la visite dans un café bombardés
par des oeufs pour l'évacuation tout est
prêt sauf les que la voiture
[Applaudissements]